[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to film
independent presents virtual edition i'm
rachel bloomer director of events for
home independent before we get started
with today's exciting conversation about
annette i have to give some praise to
our loyal supporters thank you to our
incredible lead sponsor the hollywood
foreign press association and our
screening partner vision media and with
that i'm honored to introduce our guest
moderator today please welcome variety's
janelle riley thank you so much rachel
my name is janelle riley and thank you
for joining us for this q a with annette
at this time please join me in welcoming
ron male and russell male who are the
film's screenwriters composers lyricists
and actors thank you so much for being
here thank you thank you yeah thanks for
having us
so obviously you were already
established musicians and in fact just
this year edgar wright released the
sparks brothers a documentary telling
your story but this is your first
produced screenplay
the man has changed me
what i see in her
is obvious
what she sees in me
hmm
that's a little more puzzling
so maybe
[Music]
and i'm curious how it feels to be you
know an overnight success at something
at this point in your career well i mean
it it's it's very strange because uh you
know we've always had a passion for film
and uh
i don't know that we ever considered
the idea of us being
screenwriters in a traditional sense but
we we always felt that we could sculpt
the film
you know through music and do it that
way and so so we've kind of come
around to being screenwriters in kind of
through the back door where we we've
come up with a
uh a framework of a of a narrative
situation
with lyrics and then that was kind of
molded into being a more traditional
screenplay
i don't know about the overnight success
but we we we you know we do we do feel
just such satisfaction that after
several attempts to
to do a
film movie music
movie musical that this one succeeded
and and
really on its own terms and a lot of
that has to do with leo's characters and
also just the
the passion and
of of the actors you know it was it was
an extraordinary experience
yeah every overnight success is actually
years in the making
yeah well uh this one was this one
specifically was uh eight years in the
making we uh
we had had the initial
idea um
and we had um
you know
presented it about nine years ago um you
know all of the the the music and the um
and the story to to leos we had met him
at in can nine years ago um
where we had we had gone and we'd been
introduced to him because he leos had
used one of sparks songs in his
previous movie called holy motors
and uh we learned that he was a big fan
of
of sparks of in our in our music and so
we we got together with him just thanked
him for having used the song in his
previous movie and then we got to help
back to la we thought just as out of
curiosity uh we would send leos this
project that was
was pretty fully formed at that point
even and
and to our surprise he got back to us
and he said you know this is really
something really
special it really
reaches me in in in a few in several
ways um
let me think about it a little bit and
then he got back to us and said you know
i'd really like to direct this as my
next movie and so uh we were kind of
floored that uh that that was uh
you know his desire at that point and
and so then it was um
you know eight years from that point
where
we would be we would work with laos both
in paris where he lives and then in los
angeles where we live and kind of just
refining things over that entire
period and and in the main in the
meantime actors were being approached
for it and we were really happy that
leos had the idea initially the first
actor to be
kind of um on the wish list was adam
driver and
he had been involved with the project
for
at least five years and and so
you know to his credit as well to have
stuck with this project too um you know
when he had other thing you know uh his
star wars uh franchise was start was
starting to
unfold and stuff but he really saw
something too really special
in this project and something pretty
unique for him where he's
um you know required to sing for the
good portion of uh you know two hours
and 20 minutes so um so we're really
happy at kind of the
the passion not only of less carricks
but of adam driver and then finally
marianne cottiar and simon hellberg as
well
and what you sent to laos in the in
those early days was it songs was it
actually a completed script or you know
sort of an outline almost
well it wasn't uh
it wasn't
real it was it was a script in the sense
that this whole story was there told
through
the individual songs but there wasn't
like a a physical piece of paper you
know so
so uh and we you know that's kind of the
way we like working we we realize that
there needs to be the screenplay
uh for actors and the director at the
time of the shooting but but from our
way of working we like to work at it
purely from
uh
the lyrics in the music and working
within the story so so it was complete
in a certain sense at the time we gave
it to laos it just there there wasn't
like a bound uh
script there at that time but but there
wasn't there was a treatment so that he
could at least get an overview of it and
then there was you know close to an hour
and a half of of what would would become
the the film and you know he uh
you know he he really
you know he made it clear you know he's
a very strong directory
and you know we were aware of his you
know and had you know loved his is his
earlier films that
he has a very personal view you know
through put through his films and he you
know he made it clear
uh
in you know and not in an angry way but
just that he would need to have some
input into you know sculpting some of
the of the dialogue within the the songs
but that
but that you know by and large it it
remains what it was nine years ago there
were two
there were two pieces of music that were
added
uh at least's requests there's the final
scene called the abyss
that's my favorite song yeah well he
i mean in you know in his infinite
wisdom he he he felt that it needed that
that that peace and uh
and
and you know he was right and and the
other the other one was the girl from
the middle of nowhere that
kotiar sings in the middle towards the
middle of the film where she's kind of
explaining both her
her background and then also where she
is at the present
time and in her relationship with with
adam's character so so those were
they're actually two pretty
key pieces of
music but but there were things that
weren't there in the original but by and
large the rest of it was
i literally listened to sympathy for the
abyss like
just people are like you know there's
other songs on this album
but i just i love that and i love adam's
voice in that um i'm so glad that we're
talking after people have seen the film
because one of the most ingenious
elements of the film is annette herself
for the majority of the movie she's
portrayed by a puppet
um was that the idea from the start or
did that sort of come about in the
writing of the final script
yeah it was i mean it was actually liz's
idea to embody annette in that in that
form you know we always had we we didn't
know it exactly um
in in our initial version how the
character should be um embodied and we
thought it was a really
good choice a really great choice to to
do it that way and there's never any um
you know
any
hint at trying to disguise the fact that
that's a puppet it's not cgi it was
actually a real troupe of puppeteers
that were from france that um leo said
auditioned several one a group in japan
and some americans and then he
ultimately settled on the french troop
that really seemed to have a really good
um
handle on how to
best
do this with puppetry and and we really
like the fact too that there were
elements you know like there's no
it's no disguising the fact that it is a
puppet it's in the
the arm joints there's no there's no
flesh uh hiding the joint of the arms
and stuff and and and so we really like
that and we also like the fact that the
actors
always embrace the child as if it's a
real living breathing uh child and that
that they just everyone within the world
of annette just accepts the fact that
this is that's the that is the child and
it's always treated as though it was
real and you know flesh and blood and uh
and then also the
the final scene since everyone's seen
the movie now uh the final scene where
the
where and that's character does
turn into
you know the real child we we think was
just really uh you know it's really
moving and really touching way to kind
of conclude the film
and
having
annette be a puppet for most of the film
added to the complexity of the actors
duties because so there are quite a few
times where the actor is actually
controlling the movements of of
of the puppet of of of annette so
they're having to both be
great actors
and
singing and all the singing was done
live with in the film and then and then
also they're uh controlling uh an
inanimate object at the same time and
trying to look natural
doing it and uh you know so it it
it was pretty incredible but the the the
expressions that that
uh and kind of the
i don't know the feeling that you get
off of of annette
through the the genius really of those
french puppeteers with you know was
extraordinary and and uh
they're they they did an amazing job it
was obviously the the character of
annette is such
it's the title character and and it
needs to be done right and it definitely
was done right i actually spoke to simon
helberg and he said you know the scene
where the conductor does the reprise of
um we love each other so much he's like
you know there's a camera circling me
um i'm holding a net i'm playing the
piano i'm singing and at one point her
eyes have to close
you know and um i think he said that
like someone sort of was behind him and
sort of like reached up and closed her
eyes when the camera was at a certain
point and i was just like
the the you know the acting required for
this also they're they're sort of acting
for a net they're imbuing her
with these qualities you know because at
the end of the day it is a puppet but it
feels so real no that that uh is a real
testament to the to the actors that were
involved all through all three of them
were were so great and there's scenes
like with marianne uh kotiar where she's
um
you know playing with the child and
swinging the child around in the one
piece called la la la um you know when
you you really believe that's her her
child and uh
and and uh just how adam interacts with
the child and um in so many of the of
the scenes it's really you know really
amazing and uh on the island when he's
um
shipwrecked on the island uh just the
interaction with the
the the child and um
is pretty amazing and the in the that
one the one scene where uh
you know it was a combination of things
like the scene you described with simon
hellberg where he's actually controlling
the child but then there were other
scenes that were done
um
with the puppeteers actually like in the
the uh the row boat that's coming to the
island with uh adam driver's character
henry
and annette and you don't see her but
there's a puppeteer
uh
laying laying down on her back
in below the deck of that little row
boat and she's actually has a
video monitor in there and controlling
the uh the actions of the child so it's
pretty complex even though you don't
you're not made aware of that ever
someone you know actually made a joke
about how like well they just they used
a puppet because they didn't wanna like
it's too difficult working with children
but it actually sounds like this was
more difficult
i'm sure it's much more difficult the uh
the real live uh
uh annette at the end of the movie was
much easier to work with
and because annette does feel like a
real person or character what was the
the puppet sort of like treated like on
set like between takes was she put in a
chair and like you know just treated
with respect well it was strange because
there there were different stages of of
that net character so there were about
four different puppets at different
slightly different ages but they were
the puppeteers would be there and they
it was almost like they were babysitting
at the time in between
takes because you didn't want to treat
this as just a piece of wood
it really it really was
uh a net so it was amazing to see that
interaction between them and the and the
character that they had created
yeah i mean she's your title character
like
she can be as big of a diva as she wants
because you need her
absolutely yeah no she uh didn't but and
she didn't even claim overtime pay so
she was she got her own trailer
um
i want to talk a little bit about how
the writing process works because i'm
someone who doesn't like really play
well with others and i'm fascinated by
people who can collaborate and how you
can write together um generally speaking
are you in the same room do you sort of
like break ideas together and then go
off and write different parts or is it
always together
with with us as
as sparks yeah as as musicians and as
screenwriters i don't know if it's
different or
no i mean the the process is pretty um
you know has
different ways of uh
kind of flowing you know sometimes ron
just you know comes up with something
really specific
and at his own place i have a studio
here in my place so he but he will come
up with something really specific at his
place and then
come here and we'll actually start to
record that when having a specific to
you know start start the day off with
but then there's times where
we'll just try winging something
musically um
and for a scene that we may or may not
even know uh
you know what we're headed for that it
might be a something that
specific where we know we need this
scene to have some music so we'll try
something or it might be they're just
trying to write something not knowing
what it ultimately will be for so it's
kind of
a little bit haphazard the whole
process but uh we kind of
have been doing it now for quite a while
so we kind of just know the parameters
of what's what's involved and it's kind
of despite being haphazard something
always uh results in in the in the end
one thing that we wanted to
to do with with when we were writing a
net was not worried about there being a
unity to the
musical styles of uh that were in the
film that if if there were kind of uh
uh
places where it felt abrupt that that
was okay that there didn't have to be
kind of this that oh that that's the way
the music sounds through the whole film
and so
and you know prob you know probably that
comes from the fact that we
work you know usually in three and four
minute discrete songs but but we
realized you know from the very
beginning with this with the annette
project there is a narrative
that's you know over two hours long and
that has to kind of continue so even if
there are those abrupt changes there has
to be some kind of
feeling that it's
working with pieces that have come
before it
the whole process was also i think a
little bit easier because we knew leias
has always been a you know a fan of
sparks music so
he accepts that kind of uh
potential incongruity stylistically
between pieces and i think he kind of
relishes it in fact that it that it's
not going to be
necessarily one style they're like the
opening piece so may we start as kind of
more
a traditional band sounding piece but
then there's the the next piece that
follows up um
uh true love always finds a way
uh is is really different stylistically
it's more orchestrated and and stuff so
kind of that that thing of their not
being necessarily a you know a logical
flow stylistically between
scenes of music i think laos really
really uh relished that fact but we were
always aware of their having to you know
that this was a
narrative
film
piece and that that there had to
you know in in some sense in the end it
had to feel
cohesive
and uh
and not just
that you're
when you see it written on on the page
as a screenplay but that when you
actually
you know hear it and experience the way
the audience would that it has to feel
cohesive in some kind of uh stylistic
way we we always had confidence
in laos's ability to
to uh
can to actually
make these musical scenes happen because
in every one of his films even though he
hasn't done a musical before
there is one strong musical scene and
they're always extraordinary
and
so so you know we knew that if he were
given the permission to do a to do it
for an entire film that that he he would
know how to do it
i have to ask a question for me because
i have
as you probably figured out like
listened to this soundtrack and studied
it like the zabruder film basically um i
mentioned that you
are actors in the film is where well you
obviously appear at the start you're the
pilots um are you journalists in the six
women have come forward song
no that's the one scene
sorry uh that's the one scene we're not
in but we're uh
we're in a few a few other
spots where uh we're audience members in
one of henry mchenry's performances and
we you brief
let us briefly pans across and he
suggested for whatever reason lance
wanted me to
to be a woman
in that scene
okay how much am i being paid and and uh
and um so i'm sitting next to ron and
ron's got a
sort of a a different style uh mustache
and he's wearing a hat so we're in that
scene and then we're in the uh
also in the scene
where henry mchenry is uh adam's
characters being uh
escorted away to to prison and the the
song is um
he is a murderer and so at the very
final thing before he's going underneath
into the parking garage uh
were two spectators who are very angry
at what uh henry has done and were
throwing objects at him and ron managed
to toss a hat that lands right on
at the side of adam's head
that was ron
i was i was a little bit concerned
because you know i if i if i were
responsible for uh
uh putting uh
adam driver on the disabled list for a
couple weeks it would have weighed
heavily on my conscience but
he uh he kind of
ignored it in a good way
so basically you're everywhere except
the one song i was convinced
basically that's it
we are in that scene uh
vocally uh no that's what i thought yeah
oh yeah vocally why
yeah vocally there's a there's a lot of
us there's actually yeah uh yeah the why
why come forward now one of them is ron
and and then i think there's an answer
to that and then i say why why come
forward now and those voices are ours
even though
you don't uh hear the you don't see
those characters on screen but we're in
that and and a lot of the beginning of
that is
uh a lot of me uh
uh shouting out six women have come
forward each with a different story uh
yeah so
so we are there in yeah and in spirit
um of a greek spear greek chorus is used
a lot in the film and and russell was
often a part of of those
voices where they're speaking about what
is going on or what may be going on at a
certain point there's a lot of me on the
true love always finds a way
where it is off off screen and like ron
said it's the intent was to be more like
a greek chorus commenting on
sort of a basic a basic theme in the in
the movie even in that one particular
piece you're saying true love uh
always finds a way but true love often
goes astray and so that uh
that
that singing is mine in there
so this may be sort of a strange
question because again i'm i'm i'm sort
of lumping screenwriting and be
musicians together but i think it's
appropriate in this case um do either of
you ever encounter writer's block
where you just you know give you
you're just stuck and how do you sort of
get around that if you do
i think the only way to do it is kind of
not to retreat but to attack you know
and so so whenever there's a moment
where you just don't know where to go
i rather than just waiting for that
lightning bolt to kind of come down uh
you you just have to keep working and
and you know just having done this for
so long have the faith that that there
will be a solution it just might be
incredibly frustrating to get to that
that point so
it it never it never paralyzes us
because we just don't
we don't allow it to and and and
so you know people ask about our writing
process and it's you know it's it's
incredibly
uh sloppy and you know it's not like
smooth
but in the end
all that matters is what is
there you know in the screenplay and and
in the song and the finished film people
don't have to know
so much about how uh disorderly the
whole process was but you know we just
we
you know we we just don't allow writer's
block to
to uh to to stop what we're doing
because we feel so passionate you know
in in particular within that that we
felt so passionate that we we could
never allow anything like that to to get
in the way and you know it
the the film
the the writing of the net where the
parts that were kind of uh augmented
once laos came aboard you know film is
such a collaborative process you know
you mentioned before just the
collaboration between russell and myself
but just
the that film is such a
you know a collaborative process in a
much much larger sense and in a certain
way the stakes are
are higher so that you know that's
something that we
you know kind of tried to
to adapt to and and when
when other people are making suggestions
then you have to kind of figure out how
to interpret that and and
do it in a way that is within what
you're capable of of doing and you know
sometimes it's it's difficult you know
because
sometimes uh a director is not
always conversant with with musical
language and then you know and so it and
but you you kind of are able to
learn early on to decipher what what
they're getting at
i know that you obviously have a day job
as musicians that is going very well um
but you were also named two of varieties
10 screenwriters to watch
based on this movie and so i really not
to be greedy but i really want to know
when you're going to be doing another
movie or what are you working on if
you're allowed to talk about it
yeah well we're you know we were so
motivated um by the whole
process within that and um so we you
know we
you know after can you know we're you
know you're you say us is amazing and
it's amazing and i want to go back there
again so we uh no so we started working
we were now
you know
well into another movie musical project
and we uh you know we just we really we
like having both things sort of going on
simultaneously we're also in the midst
of a new sparks album but i think both
things really um
give us different ways to channel our
our you know creative
impulses and stuff and and in different
ways and that both things are kind of
complementary to each other so so yeah
we're really excited about it uh this
new
new movie musical project that we're
working on and uh yeah if not next
year's can we'll we'll get back there
for if it's not ready yet it uh we'll
we'll get back there oh fantastic
and obviously with the sparks brothers
documentary coming out this year it's i
know it's not like you had some master
plan where these two movies would come
out in the same year and it would be the
year of sparks but i'm gonna i'm gonna
borrow a phrase from my colleague chris
williman because i just love the way he
phrased this he said you guys are sort
of known as being underdogs in the
business and now with all the success
you might be over dogs
um are you feeling the pressure of that
i think we'll take over dogs any day
of the year i mean i think all of it
just kind of
motivates you more to want to
to do uh
you know to to prove it wasn't just a
fluke uh you know this the situation and
so i think it just really motivates us
more and i think it it gives us
confidence too that we've
we've done one kind of major movie now
and that that we in we know the process
better and we we know a lot of the um
you know just
what's involved and i think so it gives
us even more confidence to be able to
try new
things and always you know and i think
that we we have a certain
niche we we think that um
in doing in how to do a movie musical in
modern times you know that that that
isn't kind of relying on past
conventions of mo of movie musicals and
that's something that we we think that
we um
now you know been given more confidence
to kind of pursue that kind of now
after having done a net and so we're
really yeah we're really excited about
this next project we're working on
well i want to remind everyone that the
movie is available on amazon prime so
you can watch it again again i'm going
to go now and try and find you in the
audience as a woman
i can't believe i missed that i went
glasses with really cool sunglasses too
oh wait i might know who you are okay
okay i think i i'll
um i love this movie so much i just
realized i made a pun on one of your uh
song titles sorry about that
um but i love it so much i want to thank
you so much for being here and thank you
everyone for watching thank you for
having us
[Music]